well I think he's an idiot I mean I
think saying anything about the number
of people you killed
and my my father was in the second world
war and I once asked him as a child that
he killed anyone and he was very
reluctant to say anything about it and
uh so I didn't understand it someone
said this morning uh he's put a Target
on his back and I think that's probably
about right
the stuff about Camilla I honestly you
know it's dirty learning in public it's
not quite Cricket really so do you think
he's gone too far absolutely far too far
I don't know if Tim or whether it's his
missus but
completely out of order
a little bit sensationalist to be honest
I think
um I think the damage is probably
irreversible now unfortunately and um
yeah probably nothing like we've seen
before it seems quite quite
unprecedented
um and yeah I think unfortunately um the
the damage has really been done this
time
Good Friday
I'm just staggered by the machine gun
Revelations and accusations that are
actually in the book you know I thought
Oprah Winfrey was bad enough and then I
thought the Netflix documentaries were
uh where they went worse than the Opera
where people went they went that great
but they this is this is Sensational
stuff if you're a journalist but if you
remember the Royal Family
I would have thought you were um holding
your head in your hands
then this is a man who has been
complaining about his security uh at all
and he's now put himself back right into
that fighting Lane again uh by this by
by this um uh bragging or killing 25
people
okay my first reaction when I read that
Harry was effectively boasting of
killing 25 Taliban fighters through six
sorties in his helicopter gunship was
one of outrage actually they may have
been enemy Fighters but they're still
people
and speaking to military friends and
also Ben McBean who was one of Harry's
friends in the Army he said to me we
just don't do that you might talk about
it within your regiment or within your
group you don't talk about it on Siri
you don't talk about it externally
because it's it is an effect it's work
but its effect glorifying death and
that's not good you just it's just not
done William and Harry were once so
close they lent on each other when their
parents divorced particularly after the
death of their mother Princess Diana
William was almost like a surrogate
parent as well as older brother to Harry
to see the breakdown of that once so
close for Eternal relationship is hugely
upsetting and sad
[Music]
they are polarizing Harry and Megan and
I think that this new book by Harry
probably won't change many people's
opinions I think if anything I think
that Netflix might have made Netflix
series Mighty made Harry and Megan a
little bit more sympathetic generally I
think this autography many people would
think he's completely lost the plot
the likelihood of reconciliation in the
short term with William and Charles I
put it precisely zero how can you
reconcile with Harry how can you talked
to Harry but everything you say
potentially going to be using a
television it will be difficult to see
in the long term if there is ever a
billion of a hatchet but in the short
term not not at all I just cannot see he
wants them to apologize to him there's
no mention from Harry as far as I can
recollect of any apology to them for any
of the things that he may have said or
done but he was expecting apologies from
them he doesn't want he doesn't want an
institution he wants a family well
unfortunately they're all family is a
family and it is also an institution you
can't separate that it's completely
different to your family and my family
[Music]
um I think it's a bit sad really it's a
um I think he's trying to go down the
road of um sensationalism and
um
you know I think really being part or ex
part of the royal family is such you
know they should really sort of like act
in a a more responsible way you know
bragging how many people you've killed
and
um internal fights you know normal
people wouldn't sort of like air all of
their problems at home and things like
that you know um socially so
um yeah I'm a bit disappointed because
uh you know I respect him as a person
and what he's done for this country but
the way he's going down the road now I I
don't particularly like it at all